あった
はないとかとですを使うそうですあり
表も3人くらい集まったよああ
朝が3基スプラトゥーン店をやらーん
タバコステッカーまステッカーです良い心家
このようなタバコは体によくね極力やめといたほうがいい
どうしてみてねますよねそんな尾根のタバコおっちゃいねえがこれ知ってっか
これでレース卵ってんだ今巷で話題になって俺もがしっかり動画です
モダンるがーでんした方もなんだかニコチン0
ああ0本製品はたば後でがあるいますね
つらいのねこれ何が言いたいかというとタバコと年齢幅コっぽいけどしたタバコじゃ
ねえ奴だから簡単に会はねーけど
タバコっぽいあの独特な感じが味わえるすぎするもんだと違う程度行ってみよう
これが
あっ僕らのたしなみだうそ
[音楽]
でもね
呼吸 sorry あっそうだからそんなかなタバコってのは関係者殿は体によくに
そして周りの人に迷惑をかけ超いう人のためにこのがいのない電子タバコ説があるんだ
俺や
どうぞ
[音楽]
ぐうっだらーっというわけでこれはにマアムに無臭の電子タバコなったが電子版ダーは
撮影して俺はどこ逝ってから解るかよ
ドンキだ
をにドンキら向かってどうぞしまったらエラー
勝てるのか車薬が俺は同期行ってきてどうみるってた電子タバコ全部買ってやったぞ
電子タバコっていうのは今やいろんな種類の味があってそれぞれいろんなフレーバーを
楽しめる
こんなげーろんだ時の応援したことを言ってたこれは全部
体に帰っていろんな味があるグレープフルーツミントはマスカットメッサーエナジー
ドリンク
ブルーベリー雨晴れ
姉さんミンターチャーミンちゃんにーベージュ文字ラボンターってバレークロスは
マヴェルミッドさん
ストロベリーとだけで今日なかったと2位でしょ怒ってんじゃねーぞ
一方何吸ってじっとちがーだけど今日ベータ版をいろんな味があるんだがそれぞれが
おいしい理由や電車もどれもとても美味しい味がするんだが
一個一個吸っててもルラ違うだねぇ富山で今日は電車がこれヒロなんですけど z
まとめきっと永遠にして俺が前だ
えりゃー
どんな味になるか数元気なのようなでルー
cero
[音楽]
まったくやべーる子どもえっ詰まってはものすげぇ量がキュリー俺が方が蔓延してああ
持ってかれるぞ時だ全部タバコがで終わりました
すげーローンの電子たとこだなポスカエローイ鴨田
だけどをランナーからこれをまとめて1束にしてすーっ
それがどんなことにしてるかわかる14本の電子タバコが一つになる
つまり普通に米たばこ9位する奴の14倍をられ一気に距離
形になりはい中今じゃやっぱ俺が一番知りたいなぁ実際どんな感じになるのか
そして味だほんとフルーティーな味が多かったんですげー気になるところであれだし
これじゃあさっそくエステミラ
いくは嘘
[音楽]
もしれないよねします私らナイフやるかんだろうね
白いなどの猿ちゃんと橋本環奈のかなぁ
くださいそこが付いとぅ
わっっ
うんすって言っ
あもう客座
[音楽]
すっげー嬉しい満たされたああ
ううっうぅううこれ
ではれた
本当のイジってもいい
[音楽]
何でも言い方しか出ないぞ
me
あっはぁ